hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine just like I am
recovering a little bit from a bout of
coronavirus which I had this week
fortunates on its way out it's in
remission
my niece today came over and she's a
daughter of a Japanese so she has
slanted eyes and so she says that here
in Germany people are swamping the the
supermarkets trying to get their food
before the government quarantines the
city or something
so everybody's or a lot of people are in
panic mode and I told you she's got an
advantage you know they all go to these
aisles at the supermarket when she goes
to the aisle
all she's got to do is start coughing
and sneezing I'm sure that'll clear the
aisle for anyways
we got a if the corona virus doesn't
kill us we got a conference going on in
New Sokka zombie I hit the beginning of
April 4th of April and so you better get
your bags ready if you plan to go okay
make plans you're gonna meet some great
people over there okay and I want to
make sure that people understand that we
also uploaded a book and you can
download it it's free book gives you a
good view of the Rope hypothesis how it
explains specifically all mother
nature's invisible stuff explains light
the mechanism of light the mediator of
light gravity magnetism electricity and
the workings of the atoms specifically
those five which are the invisible stuff
that mother nature does and we invite
anyone who wants to translate it that
book to any other language that he might
know okay and they need to contact us at
toca kaha mail.com
okay so if you you know another language
you want to translate the book into your
language we would really appreciate it
I'm translating into Spanish been doing
that for a little while now on and off
whenever I get a chance okay okay today
I was supposed to talk about Euclid and
Aristotle and a couple of the Greeks and
what is it infinite planes and for the
third fourth or fifth time I lost count
I got to postpone it one more time we
have something new come up you know
people who had questions and I have to
address those questions I can't let them
go by because a lot of people have
doubts out there and they say well you
know what about this you know and so
yeah I want to address those issues and
I think I'm dressed appropriately today
I'm dressed in black because I'm gonna
go to to the funeral or quantum
mechanics and that's what I thought it
as a sign of respect okay that maybe I
shouldn't dress appropriately for the
occasion okay
so yeah we're gonna celebrate not
celebrate I mean you can celebrate if
you want if that's what you want but
today is funeral day death day for
quantum mechanics at least this channel
okay so I want to make sure we bury
quantum mechanics never resuscitate
again anyone dealing with particles or
waves for that matter which is the same
thing but anyone dealing with particles
with one-way mechanisms they die today
okay anyways one of the issues that came
up is this word object and if I made a
contribution to science was the
definition of the word object
no one ever realized how important the
word object is for the purposes of
physics that you do need to have an
object to do physics for otherwise
you're introducing spirits you're doing
physics with black magic if you don't
put mediators okay and people say well I
can't see light I can't see gravity I
can't see the mediator of magnetism
and yeah you can't see and you can't
touch it because that's not the
definition of the word object and so
first we need to justify that yes in
physics we absolutely need an object to
do physics and then if we need an object
well then the first task of a physicist
a true genuine scientist right is to
define the word object so that you can
use it consistently rationally
scientifically in a dissertation in a
debate or whatever okay change of ideas
okay so let's start here we have the
universe without matter okay that's
great love it
nothing there all matter is removed from
the universe God waved his magic wand
all matter disappeared there's nothing
there's not a single atom in that
universe what's happening there do you
see any motion do you see any
interaction okay there's nothing there
you you now you see why you need an
object because without an object there's
nothing going on to begin with now what
a lot of the mathematical world does is
they introduced concepts you know they
introduced field and mass in charge and
force an energy and time wave and these
do not qualify as objects it's just that
simple they're not you can't say you
move you transferred energy that's an
irrational statement you can't say you
move the mass or that you that a field
is vibrating you can't say those you
can't say those you can't make those
statements in physics they're irrational
statements you do not vibrate love you
do not move intelligence okay
and so yeah people especially in the
mathematical world they want to get away
with that those are the explanations
they give you those are the physical
interpretation immediately you ask for a
mechanism for a physical interpretation
and they say well look the force comes
here and the energy goes here
and then here we invite Breit the field
and over there we push the mass nananana
not in science that's an ordinary speech
in religion maybe at your church your
Sunday School fine take it to your
crease to your pastor to your mullah
right that doesn't belong in science we
do not move concept we do not use those
words those four-letter words as I call
them in physics okay so that's the
starting point we get rid of all
concepts now you know here you have me
let me show you something here yeah
there you have two magnets okay the the
black ones there those rounds the
circles those are magnets okay okay so
now you see what's happening here put
them apart you bring them together and
they stick okay so now you can say that
there's an object pushing from the
outside that's a valid assumption you
can start at that point that's why I say
something different I say there's
something between these two that's
bringing them together okay but whether
you push them from the outside or you
bring them together from the inside
there better be some physical object in
there in you know either in between or
on the outside but there's got to be an
a physical object intervening and a lot
of people say well but I can't see it I
can't touch whatever is there I put my
hands around the magnet or between the
magnets I can't touch anything you know
for sure I can't see it yeah because
that's not the definition of the word
object that's why see you're using the
ordinate the definition of ordinary
speech which is what the mathematicians
have been using for the last 2,000 years
or more so they say an object is that
what you can touch an object is that
which you can see and you can't touch or
see it's not an object and that's that's
where the error is no objects not that
which you can cut your see an object is
that which has shape you can have shape
and not be able to
touch I mean I can't see the air
fortunately mother nature father
universe God and the devil all four of
them got together at the bar and they
decided that they're gonna make air
invincible because imagine if they would
have made air visible that's the only
thing we would see and so because we
cannot see the air yeah we can touch the
air I even can smell it if there's odor
you know you can smell it you don't see
it but you smell it you free you the
breeze in your face you can touch it
okay you don't see it but you can touch
it but you cannot see it and if you
cannot see it does that mean it's not an
object it's not a thing it's not a
medium just because you cannot see it
and yeah in the case of magnetism in
case of gravity you cannot see or touch
it and so people say oh there's nothing
there well no that's not the definition
of our analogy you cannot use see touch
and you're not going to determine the
presence of whatever's there with an
experiment so experimentation has
nothing to do with discovering mother
nature's father universe gods whatever
you believe in doesn't you take it to
that through an experiment you're not
going to resolve with your senses the
only way you're gonna resolve it is by
pulling back and visualizing imagining
how mother nature's doing this magic
trick okay now is there something there
yeah of course here between two magnets
here I've got a little you can see this
magnet is underwater and it's drawing
one iron filing at a time is that magic
is that a spirit that's moving all that
I'll be doing that with concepts are we
using the word force are we using the
word mass are we using the word energy
to do this is that what's pushing it a
bunch of energy no there's a physical
object that we can't see or touch but
the iron filing obviously can touch it
we can't but the iron filing does
somehow so we got a we got to figure out
how mother nature does this
trait of pulling one iron filing at a
time okay so you cannot say there's
nothing there
magnetic field is not nothing it's
something as mr. Faraday and Max Jimmy
Maxwell they said you know there's
matter in motion some kind of exotic
matter but there's something in there
that I can't see or touch but there's
something there if you say there's
nothing then you're a spiritualist and
you're in the wrong field you're in the
wrong discipline you should go do
religion you're doing you with spirits
you're doing you with black magic that's
why that's where the problem is you're
in the wrong field okay so now there is
something there we just have to identify
what that something is
and before we identify what that
something is we have to know what the
word something means what do we mean
when we say something what is something
what is it not you what is the thing
that's what we need to figure and no
one's figured that out in 2500 years
since the Greeks okay so we start with
the golden principle here okay and the
golden principle says that's what I call
it so if you wonder what call the
principle physics physics requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object sorry if you're gonna do without
an object you're gonna be doing you're
gonna say that nothing blew your house
away there was nothing there you didn't
see anything but your house just
vanished it was wipe them away well then
you've introduced spirits you're
introducing the god of the wind
elbows you know you're saying that God
did it that's what you're saying now
hopefully some physical object that you
can't see blew your house away that we
usually caught air or wind or some you
know tornado so physics requires an
object what is an object that which has
shape is there any provision for
experiments for observation for touching
for seeing in that definition hopefully
not no shape is a static concept that
means if there's a single object god
only
made one object in the universe a cube
okay that's all he made he didn't make
anything else aside from him you know
but he he banished too he just made the
box and then just went you know to never
Neverland
all you have is one object and so you
got to look at it from that point of
view you got to start at that point what
is that is that moving is that made of
parts is that does that weigh anything
does it have color all we have is one
box that's all we have in front of us
and there you have an object and so now
you have to have make the definition
with that stuff that's that's all you
got now you got to get a definition for
that box well how are you going to
define an object under those
circumstances and yeah I always say that
scientific definition of the word object
destroys all religion primarily all of
mathematical physics physics big words
there okay yeah so you need to define
the word object and here's the universe
and we have what single box right now
you can see there's no motion you say
well it's got color well that's only
because color is a way you can say
wavelength we call it a link length but
that's the same thing no problem it's
sending color to you but if you don't
you're not here the Box doesn't know
it's got color all it has is a certain
frequency wavelength okay and it doesn't
see itself so it doesn't have color it
doesn't even have color to compare
itself against and you only see you the
only reason you see colors there's a
contrast with the black stuff whatever
that black stuff is around it okay
does that thing move well we can set it
in motion okay here it is so now it's
moving okay so now you can say ah it's
moving but why is it moving because
you're comparing the box against the
frame the black frame or you know that
within which it's moving within your
field of view otherwise you know you
would still see this this is all you
would see
okay so the only reason you see it
moving only because you compared against
the frame if you don't have the frame if
you have a box in outer space and that's
all there is and you're the only other
guy you know you have your eyes your
mind whatever well then you won't see it
moving because you have nothing to gauge
its motion against that's the issue
okay so anyone who wants to challenge
the broke model should start there right
now we have people who want to challenge
the rope model but they don't know the
basics they don't have the foundations
to do physics specifically they don't
know what an object is and it takes two
years for a Mathemagician to learn what
an object is it really does believe me I
mean I had discussions with people like
father named dr. Dave for months and and
he just couldn't come up this definition
because destroyed his religion obviously
and so he argued for a long time another
guy from Portugal guy went by the
moniker fiesta these guys they argue for
a long time for many months and yeah
they couldn't get around the word object
and that's where we parted company
because they weren't willing to accept
the definition of shape why visa
destroys their religion that's why you
know the word the definition of the word
object the scientific definition or the
object destroy your religion you gotta
choose whether your God has shape or
doesn't have shape if God doesn't have
shape God's a concept and that's what
you're praying to a concept if God has
shape well that's not enough for him to
exist he needs also location there's
gotta be a straight line of direction
from God to me okay so and one of the
things you cannot use to define the word
object okay is synonyms you cannot use
any cinema and here you have a list of
some synonyms and none of these words
can be used within the definition and
the other thing you cannot use as verbs
you cannot use motion because as you
just saw before you can have let me put
it back again
here's there's no motion and you still
have a you already have an object okay
there is no motion that means up the
object the box in this case precedes the
definition of motion you need nouns to
do verbs you cannot begin by defining
verbs before you define nouns it's the
other way around
the first word of physicists must define
this that word object then you can do
whatever you want with it but first you
got to tell us what an object is and
this came about because you have a
comment here by fellow okay he says the
following if I could get in got so many
of these today so get ready and he says
the following a picture of a Treiber
is a picture it is not an object oh okay
the paper the pictures drawn on is an
object see so we go around in circles
because he hasn't defined what an object
is so he keeps going he skips the
definition and he says see the the paper
is an object well you still haven't told
me what an object is so I don't know if
a papers an object of our primer is an
object I don't Superman as an object you
know what is an object what do you mean
when you say the word object and then he
hit that he insinuated that he's gonna
accept shape you know like okay let's go
with shape but giving it little
importance so he says the definition of
shape is incomplete but let's continue
no absolutely not if the definition of
shape is incomplete because that
definition is complete
as far as we're concerned let me put it
up there where is it here's the
definition okay let me put it over here
okay the definition scientific is that
which has shape and if he says the
definition of shape is incomplete then
within that definition he's got to put
whatever predicate he wants to put to
condition it to make it conditional or
to change it so he's got to say
that which has shape in his black I
don't know whatever whatever he wants to
put in there I don't
here but he can't just say yeah it's
that which has shaved but it's
incomplete and I'll catch you later on
on that no way
no absolutely way okay so no if he
doesn't like the definition of the word
as that which has shake he's got a
qualified within the definition we need
a definition and then he also says
Bill's definition is not accepted by the
mainstream well we don't give a damn
what the mainstream
you mean the Mathemagician is that who
you're saying is mainstream these
retards who come out of Cambridge and
Harvard or those are the ones we're
gonna respect no no way they have
defined the word object in two thousand
years two thousand five hundred at least
three thousand maybe right and after so
many centuries at least many decades
they come up and they end up with
ridiculous physical interpretations for
phenomena and so no we can't accept
these people their physical
interpretations and that's what science
is about we're saying that science is
about the physical interpretations in
the case of physics right that's applied
to physics you need to explain how
mother nature runs her shop that's the
purpose that's what the Aristotle
defined physics as you know the study of
nature we need to figure out how mother
nature does her stuff out there and if
these people say well we don't care
about all that we're gonna do math we're
gonna describe and then we're gonna give
you a nonsensical explanation for how
she does her stuff you know like a part
of going to be in two places at once or
we're gonna work time then we got a big
problem with that because if that's what
these bozos came up with after hundreds
of years of doing math then they went on
a tangent they're not even within
science anymore okay
so I don't care what they measure I
think if they do experiments I don't
give they observed I don't care if they
touch they see if they make predictions
I don't care about any of that I want an
explanation for how mother nature does
gravity and if they cannot explain it
because they can't see or touch it
then that means they don't understand
the scientific method they are not doing
science they can't tell me that the
earth doesn't fly from the solar system
because time has worked and they can't
tell me a particle can be at two places
at once that's not science that's known
as religion and if quantum came up with
that definition or that notion or that
explanation and relativity came up with
the other then their part of religion
they're not part of science okay I hope
that's clear
another fellow says the following also
he gave it his best shot okay
I don't mind people trying says that
which is projected as an opposing face
in other words again he's introducing a
second object into the picture he's
saying something is facing you and
that's that's what we're gonna call an
object well that means you need two
objects to do facing when you have a
single cube in the middle of space made
of a single piece let's say God just
made it with this magic wand you have an
object but you don't have any facing or
anything like that and he talked about a
barrier well again you need another
object to have barriers facing barriers
and against all those words imply
another object and then he uses a he
proposed or introduced the words
instrument and medium those those are
synonyms we can't use synonyms that you
find the word object and any also
obviously ended up with tangibility
because that's what opposing what
barrier what hindrance impediment really
mean ultimately it means that you're
bringing tangibility into the equation
that's what it means and tangible means
you know touch there it is palpable
means that you're gonna do a verb the
moon is not an object until the asteroid
hits it touches it comes in contact with
it is palpable to the moon no we can't
use these definitions in science sorry
those are definitions of religion of
ordinary speech of mathematical physics
okay so yeah I'm not gonna answer
questions
to people who do not define the word
object first that's the first step if
they can't define the word object they
haven't gone through kindergarten
physics okay so if they want to me to
answer questions regarding the rope
model that's where they have to start
they have to know what an object is
because we're saying the rope is a
physical object and it's a what do you
mean you made an assumption yeah that's
a that's a superposition yeah sorry
that's required of the scientific method
one and second we need an object to do
physics so I have no other choice but to
do that and so if you don't understand
that you haven't gone through
kindergarten physics now you can say
well we don't need an object in physics
okay you can fight that battle if you
want
you're gonna lose but but yeah go ahead
what the hell okay now the other day I
put this up this is from the book and
when I showed there is that if you look
at yourself at the bottom of a pool like
through three meters of water you can
see your reflection in that mirror on
the other hand you can't see your your
face through a single sheet of paper
okay and so here you show you the piece
of paper I use there yeah you can't see
your face this thin sheet of paper can
you see me there now you can't light
doesn't go through the piece of paper
okay so but but you know and how many
how many atoms are there in that
thickness
how thick is that thing well it's very
thin it has less than a millimeter and
you have 3 meters of water you can see
yourself at the bottom of the pool so we
ran an experiment with my son just to
put here and here you can see the sheet
of paper we put in there and you can't
see through it on the other hand the
camera is focusing on the mirror okay
there we film ourselves through the
mirror okay
and we can see ourselves through there
but we can't see ourselves through the
thin sheet of paper that we put in
between okay I hope that's clear you
can't see the mirror the mirror doesn't
go through there your face doesn't go
through there okay on the other hand
when we put it underwater in here and
took a two feet of water and I put in
there with a mirror at the bottom of my
trashcan my kitchen trash can we filled
it up with water and after filling it up
okay give me a second here there you go
filled it with water and yeah we can see
our our image at the bottom of the of
the trashing there it is see we can see
ourselves right through the water okay
well you can film ourselves there so
yeah the point of that was to show that
yeah you can see yourself through water
in a mirror that's at the bottom of your
trash can of your pool whatever right
and so one of the comments that came
back is that Oh see you do need X you
know you do need experiment you do
experiments in science E because you did
an experiment my god it's like you know
you point to the moon and they're
staring at your finger you say no no I
want you to look at the moon uh but I
saw your finger that's how these people
are you know I'm sorry and and these are
a couple of comments that were made
regarding observation and one of the
things we want to destroy here is the
word observation and observer there are
no observers there are no observations
in science okay that's mathematical
mathematical physics okay
scientific method is you have to you
have to have a way of explaining
something in a rational manner to
another human being yeah true something
something like what yeah something like
an observation uh-huh which is not a
part of science he asked that question
rhetorically observation is the only way
only is the only reason why any
hypothesis is rooted in reality
otherwise your hypothesis is a dream
that's one common another guy said how
can you give a rational explanation to
anything physics if you refuse to make
observation bla bla bla bla bla and
experiments okay yeah in science we
don't do observations we don't do
experiments and one guy said well but
you just did an experiment yeah but the
experiment is not science it's not part
of science not even part of visit okay
and you say why how can you
explain something if you have not
observed and people missed the point
science is not gawking
you know I can I can make an experiment
all day long
I owe you my famous drop the pen
experiment okay so here goes and hey
watch closely always fall to the floor
and I do it a hundred times and I
observe it a hundred times and I measure
and I make my calculation get the
equation you don't get everything right
and make sure you get the measurements
very precisely so I did science is that
science just dropping a pen a hundred
times and saying oh yeah I did I did
science I observed I did an experiment a
hundred times repeatable Oh science a
ton I don't care what you did in your a
dark basement you can do whatever
experiment you want in your dark
basement when you come to the conference
to the scientific conference there the
physics conference we need an
explanation not for you to describe and
just tell us a little fairy tale then oh
yeah I did experiments I observed I
measured I calculated I made a
prediction that the pen would fall again
who cares about all that stuff I want to
know how the magician did the trick
that's what science is that's where you
have to use your brain make sure you
don't have to use your brain you just
take the ruler measure make a
predetermined standard and say well this
is the meter and how much is your table
measure what measured one meter and I
measured it a hundred times plus or
minus you know error factor that's not
science so observing doing experiments
and calculating those those do not
qualify science science is explanation
not observation not experimentation not
calculation not prediction none of those
science is explanation because that's
where you have to use your cocoa that's
why okay and so the fact that I did an
experiment it's not because I was doing
science I was trying to make sure that
people understood that when you look at
the bottom of a pool ten meter pool or
meter or whatever 10 feet pool that deep
you can see your face in the mirror down
there and I did a very quick back of the
napkin type experiment two feet of water
yeah you can see your reflection at the
bottom of that you know through the
water and so the question is how light
went round trip because otherwise people
will say Oh light came one way came from
the bottom of the pool to you like when
you look at the drain in a pool you can
see it through the water but people say
ok the light came to me one way no no
this is a round trip you put a mirror
down there you can see your face that
means light had to go through all that
water three feet or whatever of water
than three meters and then come through
the watering back to your eyes okay so
it's round trip that's the point is that
science no science it seems nice you got
explaining how that happened how mother
nature did that magic trick that's where
science comes in but people say oh you
got to observe well did Stephen Hawking
ever observe a black hole obviously he
did not he doesn't even know what a
black hole looked like never in his life
yes oh no you don't have to observe you
have to explain and he explained it with
mass black hole that's a long story
anyways so one fella came up there and
he says okay that I used the wrong than
a misrepresented quantum mechanics that
what I did Bill's version of white light
slows down is an antiquated a point I've
made before here is a video because we
avoid equations on this channel yeah we
have read equations that have nothing to
do with science we need to have an
explanation not equations okay so don't
take it bad it's just a question of
definitions otherwise you your job is to
define this video provides the latest
theory again I'm not saying this right
up now I'm saying that bills to
explanations which this person talks
about we're not the accepted mechanisms
so what did I say to that well here's
the transcript of what I said exactly
and
I essentially mentioned two mechanisms
in one I said let's go with number two
first when is the pinball machine the
photon just goes and hits all these
atoms that form the glass through which
its supposedly going to go through some
up some is gonna reflux I'm just going
to refract but it's gonna go and hit all
these little atoms and then go through
and that's the the pinball machine
notion of quantum mechanics well that's
been rejected by people in quantum
mechanics because they figured out that
that could be for whatever reasons so
this goes with number one which is the
one that still is involved and that is
that the atom does absorb the photon
that is what matter but quantum
mechanics says now when I did not
clarify last week because I didn't go
any detail in this is that yeah even
though the the atom absorbs it right let
me get back in here
give me a second I got so many of these
that there we go the the atom absorbs
light and then re-emits it but what
happens the way the Mathemagician x'
explained this is that when the photon
comes in it hits the atom in other it
hits the electron essentially and the
electron of course is both because they
have to make this magical assumption
it's both a particle and a wave they say
it behaves but it's the same thing to
say behave and that it is but they never
understood that so what happens if the
photon excites the electron the electron
now waves and now we have waves of
electrons and waves of photons we have
waves of light and waves of the atoms or
the electrons the valence maybe shell
that's not clear but they wave and so we
have these two waves inside the glass
and that slows the wave of light down
okay that's that's their argument
yeah and so I tried to illustrate that
and well this is the what he pointed he
this was the website he pointed to and
as you can see the tribe within the
light light is traveling into the glass
and then it changes abruptly why because
he says that's where we have a
combination of two fields or two waves
or whatever okay and that wave or that
field or whatever magical substance they
introduced in there that slows light
down because the two waves combine and
that slows the incoming light wave okay
that's their argument essentially okay
but it's the same because the point was
that the atom absorbs a photon of light
that's part of quantum mechanics you
can't change that but then what they had
to do they said well what it does is
excites the electron and that creates
waves and those waves slow down the wave
of life that's that that's your argument
okay now what what is the problem with
that well the problem is that that
contradicts the wave equation okay
that's the problem the problem you have
the wave equation and the wave equation
is that the velocity of lights little C
is equal to lambda times frequency in
other words lambda being the wave length
so you have frequency tank wavelength
and that gives you the velocity of light
these people are saying is what I showed
in the little picture that I had is an
advertisement for this video where the
car crashes against a tree or whatever
and what continues is part of the wave
and part of it stays behind in other
words the the wave flattens or shortens
right because it hit a brick wall and so
the way becomes shorter and but the
frequency remains the same and so if you
multiply frequency times wavelength you
get a velocity which is lower than light
okay so what they do is play around with
a wavelength and leave frequency alone
okay I'll illustrate that in a second
here okay and here's the illustration
then I put okay
got so many of these it's gonna take a
little time and wow this is another one
anyways you can see the waves coming
into glass okay they hit a brick wall
and within the glass they travel slower
because why
what has shrunk is the wavelength the
frequency remains the same but the
wavelength has has shortened and you can
see that the frequency remains the same
because I've put those little markers
there those lines and you can see that
every wave that passes through there is
the same whether it's in in the air on
the outside of the glass or within the
glass it doesn't matter then the number
of waves that go through that point
which is the frequency remains the same
the only thing that changes is the fact
that the wave is flattened out in other
words in the direction of motion in
other words it the wavelength has been
shrunk as is shorter okay
and so here's the picture that I hand
you know you hit a brick wall and the
car stops but the wave continues and
what's continuing the frequency that's
what continues but but the car which is
in this case the wave length has now
shrunk or stopped or become shorter or
whatever okay so so this is what they're
saying they're saying that the wave
shrunk okay in the direction of motion
because it hit a brick wall but the
frequency remains the same and that's
why the velocity of the light is lower
in the case of glass if we're gonna use
1.5 as the refractive index that means
that if light travels at 300,000
kilometers per second through the vacuum
more or less through the air when it
hits glass it's going to travel 200,000
kilometers per second what does that
mean it means that frequency remains the
same that means C equals frequency same
frequency whatever you can use that as a
constant but what changes the wavelength
it's shortened now it's smaller it's
shorter and so you have a slower speed
of light through glass that's that's the
notion that they have
what is the problem with this well let
me show you a couple of you you've
probably heard of the stack exchange
it's run by a guy named John Rennie he's
a very important guy within the world of
censorship that's what they do they
censor anyone who doesn't believe like
they do and they control these magazines
these outlets where they feed the public
whatever they want but they won't allow
you to feed the same thing through their
through their sites and the Stack
Exchange you know they had several
people someone asks this question about
light and these are the answers
he got ok and that's where you're gonna
see that these guys have no clue
whatsoever ok these are the answers from
official site here ok that's what we're
talking about ok here's the first one it
says what determines color wavelength or
frequency and one guy answered wavelet
the length of a signal defined by the
speed of light 300,000 kilometers he put
per hours per second divided by
frequency for almost all detectors a
actually it is actually the energy of
the photon that is the attribute that is
detected and the energy has not changed
by a refractive medium so the color is
unchanged by the medium color is defined
by the eye okay and only do indirectly
from physical properties like wavelength
and frequency so this guy says it's what
you see and not that something has
changed in the color has changed inside
the medium ok what's another guy say ok
because we had all kinds of opinions
here I like it because you know there's
no unanimous idea on this here's another
guy and he says refraction experiments
show it is the frequency that determines
color bla bla bla bla bla he justifies
that okay what does another guy say well
another guy says see if I can get him up
here the other guy says says frequency
of light weight does not change from
medium to medium while the speed of
light and thus wavelength does so again
he agrees with the previous guy ok and
so he says the wavelength is what string
but the frequency remains the same okay
essentially what these people are saying
is that they're saying this they're
saying that here you have wave equation
okay
and that's C equals lambda times
frequency okay what they're trying to do
is get rid of lambda or their trash
shrink it or they're only gonna play
around with lambda they're only going to
play around with wavelength they're not
gonna touch frequency why because if you
look up frequency is equal to the
Planck's constant times energy okay and
if you replace that in the first
equation and then you get little C
equals lambda times energy over you know
Planck's constant okay so what happens
energy is equal to now velocity or light
times Planck's constant over lambda so
no matter what how you turn and twist it
you're not gonna get rid of lambda okay
and and so you see in the Wikipedia very
interesting liner says as agency
Planck's constant in velocity of light
are both constants photon energy e right
changes in inverse relation to what two
wave length energy is wavelength
dependent
that's what but it's got to be because
you can't get rid of lambda
that's why lambda has to be in there and
so no matter how you turn the thing
around you can say lambda is equal to HC
over e frequency is equal to C over
lambda and eventually you come back to
where you started C goes frequency times
lambda and lambda is related to
so-called energy mathematically so you
can't get rid of lambda no matter what
you do and what these people want to do
is they say the the wave equation
essentially you know that's been around
at least since the 18th century the
lambert and euler you know these guys
came up with the wave equation which was
later modified over the years and
applied to light
after Maxwell did his magical math okay
and yeah today we have that equation we
know that little C velocity of light in
a vacuum right is equal to lambda
wavelength times frequency and what
these people want to do is say well
frequency is dependent on energy in
other or energies depending on frequency
but they want to give you the idea that
energy is not dependent on lambda on
wavelength and that's not true because
the equation says you say you can't get
rid of lamb then just play around with
one part of the equation which is what
they're doing and so because of that you
have a fight within the stock exchange
here the other opinions of the experts
okay here you have the other experts and
they say something different say
actually there is something important
all these answers are missing colors
determine by the response of the human
eye not by energy or frequency that's
one guy okay and let me get to the next
one another fella says where is it there
it is they're just so far down bring
them up okay what does one guy say well
several guys these are four different
guy what determines color wavelength or
frequency I think it is wavelength and
the other guy said my opinion both and
they are said light frequency and
wavelength are inversely proportion
which is correct there are inversely
proportional you can't get rid of
wavelength and just say I'm just gonna
play with a wavelength you know lower it
and raise it whatever you know they want
to get rid a runner only play with a
wavelength because they say energy is
frequency dependent but it turns out
energy is also wavelength dependent so
we're gonna say we haven't eliminated
lambda from there and then the other guy
says which is correct since Bo seein and
our constant there is he face frequency
for any given wavelength that's a true
statement
you can't Hut from a mathematical point
of view at least get rid or just play
around with weight and this is what
these people are saying
this is where the problem is okay the
problem is that they just want to play
around with a frequency and your let's
see if I can find it here you have the
spectrum okay this is the spectrum of
light okay
and some people sometimes put frequency
in there but most people just put the
wavelength they they just show that
light is is a function of wavelength and
short wavelength you get into the gamma
rays and long wavelength the infrared
cetera
okay you can't avoid it and under the
rope model it's very clear you know a
rope either has longer links and fewer
links or it has shorter days and many
plates that's all there is
so the Rope the rope model is consistent
with that but we do not shrink the you
can you cannot shrink just the link
length and say the frequency remains the
same okay which is what these people are
essentially saying and here you can see
it here in my good old rope okay very
simple okay okay how many links do I
have there let's see make it a little
longer here we have so we have what 1 2
3 4 links okay so if i unlock it ok now
I only have what one or two links right
there and now each link is longer okay
and I have fewer links and if I torque
it again okay now I have more links in
each link is shorter see equals
frequency times wavelength there you
have it it's the equation of a rope and
none of these bozos of mathematical
physics ever figure that out because
they never thought that there could be a
mediator between two atoms they think
that the atom just shoots one-way
bullets or arrows or whatever okay into
nothingness and if you catch it well
then you get light that doesn't work it
was from atom to atom okay you can't
avoid that under the Rope model
okay so so what is the issue well this
that was one issue the other issue here
is this fella really believes in guy who
wrote a lot of this stuff believes in
fairy tales you know you you heard of
the you heard of Bugs Bunny and Bugs
Bunny you know he watches TV this this
guy watches TV he sees Bugs Bunny there
he says you know rabbits talk rabbits
talk what do you mean rabbits oh yeah
you know I saw a rabbit talking
yesterday on TV his name was Bugs Bunny
huh and what did he say
well he said uh there it is you said
what's up doc that's what he said okay
so he kept just saying what's up doc and
every film that I saw so this guy
believes that Bunny's talk because of
this you know he reaches this conclusion
that Bunny's must talk because he saw it
on TV this is how naive he is and he
says the following he puts his comment
which made me laugh really he says the
body says bill claims that when light
goes through a desk medium it changes
links short long okay we should see a
change in color we do not we do not see
a change in color well you can't see
inside there right please look at our
evidence below it shows speed slowing
down and no changing color I said what
is this guy talking about you probably
saw Bugs Bunny and he's saying oh I
talked I saw the Bugs Bunny you know so
that's how you say that's how naive he
is he said well what did this guy see
and so this is where he sends me and I
went in noon see well let's see what
what it is he saw this is what he saw
this is from their sight tonight and
when he says he you got all that light
goes through there yeah you got this
little blob there and suddenly you got
this light going through there and
they're filming this light right and he
says it hits his bows Condon's
blob there and see light doesn't change
color he says and I'm saying what the
hell he thinks this is real he thinks
this is Bugs Bunny talking he thinks
this is real this is a real film that's
what he thinks okay
and so it just kind of made me laugh
that he took this at face value that he
thought he was looking at something that
is real that was like film like you got
your camera and you see the photons
passing by you and you said I'm gonna
film the photons and here I'm gonna show
bill that light does not change the
color remake it was always remain red
and if you go in there into this paper
because if you go to the authentic paper
the original paper you see something
like this they they have this in their
paper this is a picture from their paper
and you see the finish line and one
photon reaches faster than the other one
the one who got stuck in the
bose-einstein condensate and and so you
know he probably thinks this is real he
probably thinks there is a finish line
one photon beat the other one no this is
he thinks all this stuff is for real and
what you'll find out there is is the
following if you go to the original
paper okay because that's where you got
to really go you can't go to the
translations into for normal people for
people who are not familiar with all
these things and it says the following I
just pulled one piece which essentially
puts all of this in the proper
perspective it says a schematic of the
experimental setup light and electron
pulses pulses okay at a variable time
delay are spatially overlapped on an
isolated silver nano wire suspended on
TEM grid blah blah blah blah blah
probing the electrons are detected using
a CCD camera after passing through an
electron imaging filter aha what is what
are these four-letter words what are
they target
is a CCD camera and what are they
talking about imaging here so we got to
look that up because that's where the
key is you know that's where the mystery
is gonna be and so you look up the the
word CCD camera and this is what you
find okay so as a charge-coupled device
CCD is a device for the movement of
electrical charge this is from the
Wikipedia charge oh we got a problem
they're already charges a concept so you
can't have movement of concepts but
let's continue usually from within the
device to an area where the charge can
be manipulated such as conversion into a
digital value okay so what they're doing
is taking the movement of something they
don't know a concept charge or a pulse
or a signal right and they're gonna turn
it into a digital value they're gonna
turn it into a particle that's what
they're saying they're okay they're
gonna assume it's a particle this is a T
by shifting the signals between stages
with indeed the device one at a time in
other words they're gonna go in there
and they're gonna say hey you know
energy comes in discrete packets
according to mr. plank so they're gonna
treat those as balls as discreet balls
that's what they're doing see CDs move
charts between capacitive pins in the
device with a shift align for the
transfer of charge between bins and as
says CCD is a major technology for
digital imaging etc etc etc okay and so
we say well what the hell is this
digital imaging let's get to the bottom
of that now okay so you look up digital
imaging to find out what these people
are doing in the labs okay how they're
figuring all this stuff out says digital
imaging or digital image acquisition is
the creation of a digitally encoded
encoded representation of the visual
characteristics of an object okay
they're gonna take a signal they gotta
take a pulse and they're gonna turn it
into a ball they're gonna say we're
gonna assume that what just went through
our eyes is a little tiny ball
that's what there's doing okay digital
imaging can be classified by the type of
electromagnetic radiation or other waves
they're already assuming they're staring
out away they're gonna turn that wave
into wave packet whose variable at the
attenuation as they pass through or
reflect off objects conveys the
information that constitutes the image
they're gonna they're gonna convert
these signals into images they're going
to take that information and pulse
whatever it is and they're gonna turn it
into a particle okay and again
information is converted by image
sensors into digital signals that are
processed by a computer yeah and
essentially what has happened is that
all these see I've ever done in history
for a long time and there's something
called a photo multiplier for the
multiplier already assumes it's built
it's built already to consider all
pulses all signals as particles as
discrete particles because that's what
quantum tells them so they're gonna
build the device already saying look
we're gonna detect this electronically
they're gonna do it with electrons are
gonna try to figure out what a photon is
with electrons is that what they're
gonna do
of course you can't you can't see an
invisible and entity like the mediator
of light you can't touch it you can't
see it much lesser you're gonna detect
it with electrons but that's what they
do
so you say what are they really doing
with with this is what is this
technology well the technology is every
time you see a signal you turn it into a
wave packet what is a wave packet a
little ball and you're gonna treat it as
a digital you know little piece of
energy a ball of energy and so the
system is already designed to consider
all these things as balls to begin with
because it's designed that way and so
people say ah see you prove that it's a
particle now you didn't prove that it's
a part of you you did not see the
particle go by that's all imaging but
this guy believes that you know Bugs
Bunny is for real he looks at these
things you know so gullible that he
looks at all this stuff and he thinks
he's looking at the real thing let me
show you a couple other real
things that they fed feed the public
okay just so you're aware how these
people manage the information here you
have a file by a name of Connemara a guy
a Japanese guy who works for thinking
you for Hitachi corporation okay and
this guy he says that he did the slit
experiment said when accumulated
interference fringes are formed okay and
he says we have reached a conclusion
which is far from what our common sense
tells us for sure no doubt about it what
is he saying he's saying if you shoot
these little dots these spots indicate
individual electric electrons are
detected one by one as particles you can
be confident that electrons or particles
he's already concluded he's got this
foregone conclusion that what you're
staring at is a bunch of bullets hitting
on the wall and that's what it looks
like you know you look at them say well
he's right I mean that's what it looks
like he's shooting a bunch of bullets
okay is there any way to doubt this is
there any way to challenge this is there
an alternative well this is Tana Maura's
version of this okay that's this what he
thinks it is he thinks he's in a target
practice he's at the shooting range
right and and he's gonna create all
these little fringes with bullets that's
what he's saying he's saying you gotta
get in there with your shotgun R and
you're gonna shoot okay and then when it
comes over you can see all the holes
that you made in your target you say
this is this is this is obviously the
electron is a bullet see it just went
through and killed the Geiger you know
made these patterns okay that's what you
say and again is there an alternative to
this oh I think there is let's see if I
can find it here lost it here
give me a second here
still about true well I'm gonna have to
go with the next one until I figure it
out I wanted to show you that maybe I'll
figure it out still anyways here's uh
here's another fable that these people
tell you okay and this is a one man one
to call Anderson the Nobel Prize he says
what I found is a positron trace a
little particle that went in there made
that groove on a wafer on a piece of
metal okay and why is this nonsense well
first of all it's a su positron not a
positron he supposed that it was a
little particle that made that little
scratch okay
and why is that not possible well
because these things travel at the speed
of light this guy's saying that it made
that curve in in such a short time in
such a short distance okay and you know
the question is whether that's realistic
let me give you some more in and again
you know that these are assumptions he's
assuming that the positron is a little
ball and so he's saying you know made
that curve me that grew like you plowed
through the field well you know I mean
did the positron go up and down and make
one little hole at a time is that how he
built that or was it
you know did it plow across the field
these are the important physical
questions they're not important for him
because he's a math magician but for a
physicist these are the questions he
would ask
here's let me give you another example
here again of how these people make
claims that people take at face value
they're looking at Bugs Bunny and they
think Bugs Bunny is for real and this
one of the famous when they came lately
I think 2013-2014 this is a Swedish
group that said they filmed an electron
and you see the electron there you say
oh that's what our electron looks like
okay now we've got it all settled
there's a couple problems with this the
first one is that an electrons supposed
to be zero dimensional it has no size so
the question is what did these people
film and that's only the beginning
question there's even a more profound
question is
and I'll just go with the next one
before I answer that question or clarify
that here's another one this is by a
government agency in the United States
known as Brookhaven National Labs okay
and what you see there is the explosion
of two gold atoms they you know they
they caught they collided and from that
collision you get this image and what
they and they put that you know like
everywhere anyone who missed that is not
into physics or doesn't do any research
and then you say you look at me and say
hold it you know gold atoms it's only
got like 74 or so I can't remember the
exact number of particles and they say
no it's got more particle see what
you're looking at there is gluons and
quarks you know they they clash and they
broke up into a gazillion pieces and
once you see all these gluons and quarks
rushing away from Ground Zero so here
we've filmed the electron we've seen the
positron because it made the groove
right in Carl Anderson's suppository
paper for which we he won the Nobel
Prize
here you have gluons and quarks you know
you're talking about very small
subatomic particles you know just to put
it in the right perspective and see if I
again if I can get these I got so many
and right at the bottom sometimes they
can you mean get them right here's the
here's the quark okay so you can see
what the what the size of a quark is in
proportion right here you have a proton
and the proton is made of three quarks
also a neutron for that matter and they
have these bedsprings they call blue
gluons actually gluon is another
particle that is mediating this
transaction of course they cannot
illustrate it with particles because
particles don't pull so they had to put
a bed spring in there but you can see if
this is a proton and a proton is a small
part of the atom like a ten thousandth
part of the
entire volume that an atom hydrogen atom
occupies if a proton is is one
ten-thousandth part and within that you
have these course which are smaller than
the proton which make up the proton and
within that you have all these gluons
which are really particles gazillions of
particles that bring the quarks together
right and these people say that they've
already filmed the quarks the gluons the
electrons then the question is oh man
they should be able to draw an atom I
mean if we were filming electrons and
the electron has no size but they say
they film that okay fine let's concede
that no one should have any excuse not
to draw the sketch a hydrogen atom and
these people say well we can't see an
atom what do you mean you you've got all
these electrons and gluons and quarks
and you which is a tiny small
vanishingly small part of an atom if you
image them somehow you claim that that's
truth but you can't tell me what an atom
looks like which is billions of times
bigger than these guys we got a problem
because something is wrong something is
wrong somewhere you can't say it's it's
I give the example of the architecture
that comes to your house or the Builder
you know and you say what does my house
look like oh I can't tell you I work
with nails and I use the nails to put
the boards that make the wall but I
don't know what your house looks like I
mean if you're working at the nail level
you had better know what the house looks
like and that's the case here here these
people are saying we know what a nut
moves around looks like we know what a
gluon looks like we know what a quark
looks like but we don't know what an
atom looks like they can't draw an atom
you say why can't you draw an atom I
mean you're working at the quark level
the gluon level at the electron level
we've never seen one we don't have
enough equipment the atomic force
microscope or the scanning electron
microscope to be able to see
hydrogen atom we got a problem because
these guys are already working at
subatomic sub yeah subatomic particles
so no we got a problem we got a serious
problem because these people are making
claims based on the particle hypothesis
which is already a foregone conclusion
and that's what they build into these
devices like photomultipliers and these
c cds what they do is they already built
in the particle notion and they treat
everything as part of any blip any any
pulse any signal is treated as a
particle and so people say oh look they
proven that the world is made of
particles no it's the other way around
devices are built based on quantum
that's how it works and so everything
will be confirmed from now on because
all the devices are made to detect
everything as particles they turn
everything into digital pulses they've
never seen the mediator of light they'd
never seen a photo but this guy believes
that they film the photons you see the
photon doesn't change its color when it
goes through the bose-einstein
condensate he really believes his
looking at Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny
and who knows what and he thinks that
it's really Mickey Mouse there no these
are all images these are images that
these people fabricate to give their
physical interpretation that's why the
color remains the same that's the only
reason okay okay moving on here let's
see if we can do a little closing three
I'm gonna go a little over time I guess
because I need to cover a couple
subjects here maybe I'll keep them for
the next time who knows this guy says
issue with light under water bill says
that when light goes through water then
the electromagnetic rope change
wavelength and frequency yeah he
explains this by saying the links get
longer uh-huh not shorter they get
longer that's why and again here you
have it frequency times wavelength okay
so the when it goes through a denser
medium what happens is the Rope becomes
in other words the links become longer
and there's frequency changes in inverse
proportion that's what it is that's what
C equals frequency times wave length
means that's the equation of a rope and
as you can see they try to keep hold
frequency constant but wavelength they
shortened him you know they play around
with the wavelength and this guy doesn't
understand that he thinks that there's
no change in color inside there but he
says this means that the color that we
should see will change from white
average of all cause above the water to
red or any other color with a longer way
and I don't know where he got that and
all he's putting words in my mouth he's
his interpretation is his only I don't
know where he got that when you got to
see the paper that he references okay
see if I can find in here I need I need
a secretary okay okay well he just
insisted on that he's saying he comes up
with in notion he said but we know that
colored light has different penetration
rates through water this shows red
penetrates only a few meters versus blue
which penetrates hundreds of meters seen
many times by underwater camera man and
scuba divers and he references an
article which again I pulled up in build
is correcting the electromagnetic links
get larger then we should have a red
ocean I don't know where he got that
that's his interpretation okay and
anyways I went to see the article see
what he's talking about
and the article says exactly what I
thought it would you know no no
difference from what the paper said and
what the rope model proposes there's no
contradiction and here's the paper okay
this is the picture you can see what
he's talking about you saying when light
like from the Sun hits an ocean well you
know the high frequency rays like blue
in this case go deeper and the red ones
you know the lower frequency the longer
wavelength don't go as deep and that's
got to do with again with the frequent
so-called energy content okay no problem
with the rope model were you saying that
long link is cold short link hot very
soon
hi that's all it is and the hot ones
have obviously more energy that's the
word the mathematicians use to say
something that that's got short
wavelength and yeah it's hot and it's
got higher frequency higher energy
because of that and it goes deeper no no
problem we have no difference with what
these people figure it out there okay
there's no contradiction and let's see
if I can see okay these so so when light
goes through a medium like in this case
which I showed the other day okay with
particles which is what they use right
they have to use Snell's law and they
say look what changes here is the is the
wavelength
okay the wavelength is which shortens
and because of that light travels slower
because the only way you can you're
gonna get a proper version of white
light travels slower through a medium is
if you shorten the wavelength if you
keep the frequency constant in other
words here what we're doing is saying
essentially the following if you have
let's say just give an example of 500
not nanometer wavelength times whatever
frequency the only way you're gonna get
a slower speed of light is bringing that
wavelength to say 400 and now you have
400 nanometers times the same frequency
and of course you're gonna get a lower
number and that's that's what they do
with a refractive index but what is the
physical interpretation well they say
the the explanation is first that the
atom absorbs that incoming ray of light
okay that Photon and because of that it
vibrates and because it vibrates okay it
it forms its own ways the you can say
the electron waves okay inside the
inside the layer and so you have the the
wave of light and the wave of the the
elect
and they kind of mix with each other and
because they mix like go slower through
the medium that's how they explained it
today okay but again we have no
mechanism why first they they use a
magic wand to convert it into a wave
there's no such thing as a wave in
quantum you don't believe me go to look
at the standard model see if you see
anything called wave in there that's all
particles all little balls little beads
they have all these names you know glue
on and proton whenever there are little
beads and so you won't see the word wave
in there you'll see a transverse wave
but they use the transverse wave when
they need to explain these kinds of
things or or maybe the slit experiment
or whatever that's when they introduce
the wave it's a nagging problem that
mother nature imposes upon the
Mathemagician so they they don't like
the way but they have to accept it
because mother nature says you know the
light behaves as a wave and they can't
get rid of that Maxwell told them that
they can't get rid of that okay so so
they use the wave and so that's the
first problem they use a wave there's no
such thing as a wave because when you
say what's a wave well there's all these
particles that are waving so we're back
to the particle and so whenever that you
talk about waves are talking about
particles but they're saying the
particles called photons and the
particles called electrons they move
together and why would that slow light
down we still have no mechanism you know
they have to illustrate that for us say
well why does it move like that why does
the wave of light move slower because
there's a wave of electrons what is the
wave doing to the wave in other words I
mean if there are all particles right
and again these particles traveling
through or are they already there and
waving one on top of the other I mean
what's the mechanism I need to see a
film of this and this is what we don't
find we don't find a mechanism of
physical interpretation all they say is
oh we have one wave and another wave and
one goes slower the other ones faster
they both superimpose and the guy that's
coming in he goes slower that's what
they're saying you know and so yeah
that's
that's what we have to this day here we
have see if I can pull it up here see if
this one's it now this is the quantum
and see because it all comes down to the
atom unless they can draw an atom we
cannot begin to talk about the wave we
cannot begin to talk about light or
anything else we need to know what an
atom looks like and specifically we need
to know what's between an electron and
the proton we need to know what's in
that region in a hydrogen atom this is
this is what they need to identify if we
if they can't identify that region there
they cannot draw their atom because
their atom is just you know one ball the
proton which is made of those quarks and
the gluons and you have the electron on
the outside so what keeps the electron
faithful to that nucleus to that proton
I need to identify that region between
the electron and the proton and unless
we get that we cannot even talk about
waves we cannot talk about electrons
flowing as little beads because we still
don't have an atom how do you know the
electron is a little ball a little bead
when the electron has no size according
to them the proton has no size retired
about sizeless things and what is the
thing it's that which has shape these
people say these things don't have shape
so what are we talking about what are we
moving here concepts how can you talk
about the flow of electrons making up
electricity for example or how can you
talk about the electron being I or the
atom being ionized when you remove an
electron what keeps it there to begin
with please draw your atom and I don't
care of mother nature's real and I want
your atom I want you to draw your atom
what are you visualizing when you say
that electricity is the flow of
electrons or that the when there's a
quantum jump when the little bead goes
back and forth between energy levels it
emits and absorbs photons what do you
mean by that I mean what do you mean
this little ball jumps back and forth
and somehow it emits creates photons
and absorbs photons little balls so so
you have a little ball that's going back
and forth a size less ball right and
it's absorbing and emitting another size
of this ball called the photon so far we
have nothing in front of us that's what
we have from a visit from physics point
of view and unless they clarify that us
you can give me a model of your atom and
again I don't care about mother nature's
atom or the real Adam I want your atom I
want you to explain in your own terms
what that what your atom looks like just
brought very simple I mean we're talking
about two particles how difficult can it
be you got a ball proton and you get a
little ball an electron fine what keeps
the electron bound to the proton and if
you cannot justify that you got a
nonsense atom and of course you're not
going to understand anything and you
should not be able to explain light or
any of these other features of of
quantum mechanics what quantum mechanics
alleges and that's where quantum
mechanics fails it fails because it has
not determined what light is because it
has not determined what an electron is
which because it has not determined what
an atom looks like but see they make all
these claims that they filmed the
electron moving then they can film a
photon which is this but this guy
proposed he says doesn't change colors
when it goes through the bose-einstein
condensate they have already film and
talked to and interviewed the quarks and
the gluons which are inside the nucleus
which is the 10,000 part of an atom
they've seen all these tiny ones but
they can't tell me what an atom looks
like they cannot draw an atom for me and
when they do they can't justify how the
electron remains faithful to the proton
so yeah that's where they should start
and so you know what I'm gonna do anyone
who wants to criticize the rope model
has to start by defining what an object
is and then it'd be nice if they draw
first their atom I want an atom
a picture of their Adam they can point
to it anywhere on the internet and say
look here it is here's my Adam and I
don't care about mother nature's Adam I
want their Adam it's just you and me but
on this island there's no one behind you
so don't look behind and say all these
guys stand behind their they all
approved the Maya no no it's just you
and me we're just alone on the island so
all you got to do is draw your Adam and
justify it you got to say look this is
how the electron remains faithful to the
proton if you can do that hey I'll eat
my words anyways I'm gonna continue a
little bit along these lines on
Wednesday because I haven't finished
here completely and I want to cover a
couple more points just too lengthy to
cover all these little details but the
bottom line is I need an object in any D
item so anyone who wants to challenge
any part of the rope model has to
produce those two and by the way if you
want like extra credit tell me how two
particles can be at the same place at
the same time because people say oh but
know your ropes go through each other
everybody asks that question but nobody
asks well how can two particles go
through each other
how can two party goes be in the same
place at the same time how can one part
of go be at two places at the same time
no yes everybody takes that as a given
because it comes from the scientists
mathematicians so that's okay you know
you don't question that but the first
thing people question about the role
model is touching seeing and we say that
you know you can't see or touch the
mediator of light so yeah that's extra
credit for anyone who wants it but first
object definition how do you define a
word you put the word object : and some
words after that that's the only way
that's going to be accepted you can't
say well let me explain it nananana we
need a definition object colon followed
by words that define the word object
that's the way it works okay that's the
first step the second step hey Brian
Adam for me any atom you can draw the
hydrogen atoms the simplest so that's
when I suggest and justify how the
electron remains
faithful to the proton then we can start
okay
and that's before you can make any
criticism of the rope model because that
means you have nothing to offer indeed
alternative and you haven't gone through
the kindergarten class of physics we'll
see you on Wednesday bye bye